now just before we dive into this I
thought it would be helpful just to step
back a minute and give some context
right why do we care about any of this
can you think back to a moment for a
moment back to this guide remember this
is a Greek letter which Greek letter is
it it's Delta thank you very much by the
way were thumb worth distinguishing
because you're here in the extension one
course that's a capital Delta this is a
lower case Delta it's like an eight but
you didn't quite finish it that's the
way I think about it anyway
we'll use the lowercase Delta and
another topic later on polynomials the
capital Delta though we learnt it in
which topic it's it's the discriminant
which belongs to what kind of functions
court radix right now we care about the
discriminant for what reason why is it
useful to us it's it's not in the name
sort of in the name because it disgrace
what does it discriminate between we did
talk a lot about domain arrangement not
so much I mean it is sine it sort of
related but it's a little bit sort of
off the side wrestle yeah we're going to
get right so you functions who related
the demeanor but think max your
quadratic equations all of which hand us
functions the thing that was interesting
was mainly how many real roots do you
get out of a quadratic equation right so
for example if the discriminant is
negative what does that tell you how
many real roots we have you won't have
any real roots if the discriminant is
negative or if you have the discriminant
how do you get if that's zero real roots
how do you get just one real root what
does it it's good it can be equal to its
going to be equal to zero exactly and of
course the last case is if the
discriminant is positive which seems to
you but most of the cases and we do it
good morning and that gives us two real
roots now the reason that's useful is if
you can know what kind of a quadratic
you're dealing with before you even
start to find roots or whatever right
sometimes you can make a pseudo decision
sometimes this is all you're interested
in actually that's why we're interested
in classifying things why it's useful to
know this is an you know these things
are insects because they have six legs
these things are acting so they have
eight legs as soon as you know that as
soon as you know the number of legs you
know this interesting information that
sort of you know is corollary to that
and it's the same deal with functions
and relations good morning why do we
care about these kinds of labels not for
their own sake they're not an end in
themselves they are a means to an end
they help us understand and later on
especially when we deal with the topic
called inverse functions being able to
answer these questions quickly and
immediately saves you a heap of work
later on if you just know from the
beginning you know which of these which
of these categories do I fit in which of
these classes okay now this is like I
say in the heading somewhat review so
hopefully you can help me with this
right the key question when we look at
any of these one to one may to one one
to many many to many the key is it's all
about your domain and range okay so one
to one it's about how many values in
your domain sort of relate to how many
values in your range right your x values
how many Y values do they match up with
and vice-versa okay so for example let's
do a simple example over here and I've
got four you don't have to make them
very large just like 20 cent coin size
little graphs will do if you have a
graph like a straight line right or even
like ice on a wiggly line like so okay
every single x value that you can think
of right for example if I put on an x
value like here right it matches to each
single x value matches to precisely a
single Y value so if I just sort of go
up I'm like look there is there's the Y
value that corresponds to in fact
correspondence is a really important
word here it's another word for the big
category the big family of objects to
which functions and relations belong
each x value corresponds to exactly one
y value and that's why we call it that
right now you might remember you got
introduced to real color you had
introduced this thing called the
vertical line test do you remember that
the vertical line test yep so this is
the whole idea if you take literally huh
need to bring some up if if you take
that's really funny I'm just going to
use this alright
right if you take any vertical line
right like this guy here and if you
place it up against the entire object
that you've got it is important that you
go all the way through you can't just
taste like a particular spot you're like
yeah this spot works you got to be able
to it for the whole thing as I draw my
vertical wire across the graph it always
only ever intersects once with the graph
okay so another way we would say that is
this guy here and any one-to-one
function good morning with regard to the
vertical line test it passes so it sort
of gets a tick right okay now when we
think about many-to-one
again this is about the x's and how they
relate to the Y's so the idea here is
there are some kinds of objects whereby
there are several x values and when you
put them through you like substitute in
the x values you might get the same y
value out for different X values many
X's will get the same y now we were
looking at discriminate before because
they were about quadratics and that's a
perfect example of a common many-to-one
relationship let's draw a parabola like
so and you can see there are several x
values that will map to the same y-value
let's pick a y-value okay Y value like
say up here okay now if I ask you which
x value corresponds to this Y value you
could equally say over here see how it
matches up there is an x value that
matches with this Y value but it's not
the only one is it right I could go all
the way over here and there's another x
value that's all the way over here on
the negative side there are many x
values one and two that correspond to a
single Y value okay and again if I take
my vertical line you can see it goes all
the way across and it never intersects
more than once so with regard to the
vertical line test as a pass or fail it
passes thank you so yeah vertical line
test it passes now why are we interested
in the vertical line test what does the
vertical line test to help you know it
like not just it passes or fails but
what does that tell you again it's one
of the words in the
in the heading this is a it's a function
very good thank you very much so just
like saying it passes the vertical line
test that's kind of synonymous it's
literally exactly the same thing you say
these guys here they're both functions
and anything that is one to one or many
to one will be a function so I'm going
to actually suggest you do something
like this these guys here they are
functions it's really asking about do
you get one by Y value out for any x
value that you put in that's what makes
a function you can see how there's two 1
y 2 1 Y that's what makes it a function
that's the definition